le confinement se prêtait vraiment bien
mettre en valeur ce morceau que voilà
laissez-moi firme propose dans ce monde
hostile faire fleurir des roses presque
sans épines c c'était vraiment ce qu'on
était en train de vivre les données on
va dire une petite pause d'espoir et en
même temps on était seuls tous chacun
chez chez nous et j'ai eu l'idée de
concevoir la 2de le clip et demandant à
toutes les personnes qui m'ont prêté au
jeu je connaissais bien de tourner des
images d'elle même avec leurs annonces
et envoyer leurs vidéos se rendre au
débat ce qu'ils ont fait dans l'excès la
vérité tu sais peu de gens y ont accès
c'est un morceau qui était mondiale a
été effectué avec un groupe de gospel et
blues gospel choir ils m'ont apporté
beaucoup de force
ils sont venus chanter un refrain que
j'avais écrit et non après coup là la
puissance que moi j'aurais pas pu
apporter sigefi ci avait été tout seul à
le chanter il défendre des causes justes
avec mes quelques rimes
aiguisé ma prose pour voir les
consciences qui s'illumine
laplaud ma
[Musique]
pourquoi changer les couleurs dans ce
futur qui a dit
[Musique]